hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan today I'm
going to answer a question about getting
sponsorship for a music program from one
of my readers so let's take a look so
this question came in from Amy thanks
for the question
so Evan congrats on all the hard work
you put into your videos and all success
we've had your website just popped up I
said we help entrepreneurs I hope it can
help me I'm never gonna run a million
dollar business but I do hope to help
others my name is Amy I'm a moocher
graduate and I maintain a studio for
private and group musician instruction
which really means I make very little
money
however I'm currently in the process of
establishing a music scholarship program
for low-income and disadvantaged
families I'm seeking sponsorship donors
sponsors in behalf of these prospective
students I know a little bit business I
just want to help those less fortunate
we're going to do something everyone
should be able to do take music lessons
but I hope to do is gain music donations
donations for scholarships and set up
something that'll be self-sustaining
ongoing allowing new students be
scholarships each year so thanks for the
question Amy it's a great initiative
congratulations I want to set that up I
think a part of any business should be
to also contribute back to the community
around you it not only you know makes
your community better but it also makes
you feel good and you know you're doing
some good in the world so in terms of
getting sponsorship this can be a tough
the tough challenge is a lot of
competition that you're going up against
I think to make this work what you want
to do is find people who have a interest
in music so why would somebody want to
you know put money into this instead of
another charity right you're going up
against some some big big dogs and
people are used to donating a certain
amount of money to certain charities
every year one thing that may be a
challenge is that you're you're you know
probably not set up as a charity so to
be able to accept donations then you
want to be able to give tax receipts
people expect to be able to give tax
receipts so you know that's another
incentive to want to give money so if
you're not able to do that yet you may
want to partner up with another charity
or have them octoscope it's called a
fiscal agent so there your fiscal agent
and they basically allow you to create
tax receipts in total you know legal
ways you partner up with the charity and
they're going to
you the money donors give the charity
the money and then the charity gives you
the money that might be a big hurdle
that you'd have to overcome to try to
get people to to give you money for what
I try to do is tell the story - so talk
about some of the people who you have
helped or the people who you want to
help and you can see the impact that
you're having so if you're already
giving some lessons or if you're doing
some for free on the side just to start
helping out see if you can even do a
little video clip to have them on camera
and say here's how music has changed my
life and I've come from here and I've
gotten to here because of music and I
couldn't imagine doing anything else do
you want to have a story that kind of
tugs at the heartstrings because your
competitions all doing it right all the
other charities are doing something
similar as well but hopefully by doing
that and then reaching out to people
within your community you'll get
probably going to find sponsors from
people who are in the local area instead
of a tan a tional international although
you know you never know you can look at
projects like Kickstarter which raises
money for these types of initiatives
some are you know just funding for
different projects in the arts and some
are actually to set up a business but
you can check out Kickstarter com
and if you had a video that clearly
explained what you're doing and shows
the emotional and unreal impact that
you're having then that will make it a
lot easier to people to convince
somebody to be able to give you money so
I look at a couple of resources again
just to recap look at places like
Kickstarter com look at your own local
community and I'd also try to find a
fiscal agent to be able to accept
charity receipts for me so I can be be
of charity and not just be a regular
organization apart from that you want to
figure out definitely how much you need
so establish as part of your marketing
to know how much does it take to sponsor
one child for a year right what's it
gonna cost me to be able to do this so I
can get a clearer understanding of the
impact that I can have and how much it's
going to cost so hopefully that helps a
great question for those of you watching
if you like the video please give it a
thumbs up it makes you want to do more
of these videos for you and I'll also
hear I'd love to hear if you have a
comment on this video some extra
suggestions that you want my to give
and also if you have a question about
your business I'd love to hear it
please leave in comments below it makes
me always makes my day when I see
comments coming in so thank you and
you'll see you in the next episode
you